[Music]
so first of all just congratulations
on this oscar nomination it's incredible
i wanted to ask where were you when you
first found out you were nominated
what were your reactions your emotions
what was the first thing you did
i was in where max is right now
and then i just started cursing that's
what i do
my phone was calling and i just picked
up and some it was something like
someone
was having like a feverish dream or
something he was just like kind of
gibberish saying stuff and he was like
go over here come over here and i
didn't know where he meant so i i went
from the other end of the studio
out in the hallway and it sounded like
the building was on fire but it was it
was only saban
sort of screaming that it actually
like it actually happened like call your
family
remember this
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i was actually at home i set an alarm
and was up at five in the morning and uh
listened to the announcement
and remember it like one after one and
i'm like oh my god and then
nikki was announcing he passed and then
he said who's a week and i just like
started screaming
obviously woke up my girlfriend i'm like
it's happening
and i texted these guys like guys i
think we got it
because even at that point you're not
sure because it's so surreal it's like
i'm like i don't trust my eyes like that
nick jonas
prankster no he's great
no it's still surreal even hearing it
now and talking about it
it just never gets old so starting from
like the very beginning i'm curious
i think as a kid when you think about
like being a musician
as a dream job you think about being a
rock star
a pop star you don't necessarily jump to
songwriter producer when do the three of
you
first become aware of that like being a
job and something that you're attracted
to doing
i mean i was in a boy band in high
school
and i sent out a demo tape to just
random a random address that happened to
be drive records
and i got a call from this guy named
dave mcpherson and and it was like 7 30
in the morning when i woke up from
school
when i woke up it's getting ready for
school and he's like a sovereign kataka
there yeah and it says
you know so i somehow got this demo tape
on my desk it sounds like [ __ ] but my
my assistant put on my task and i
listened to it
and i used to just make demos by pushing
record
you know i didn't really know what i was
doing i was pushing record and i didn't
was too lazy to learn other people's
songs so i would just write
and he goes i just signed this band
called the backstreet boys
and i want them to record this song
and i said well you know i have a boy
band and i was hoping that
you know we would be performing this
song like a to
school like a school talent show thing
and
you know i was going to try and i want
to try and get a record here because i
didn't know drive records was like a big
label
and he was like listen kid i could tell
by your name
that you're not white and i said yeah
i'm indian he goes
you know i'm a black american so i'm not
saying this in a racist way but he goes
no girl in wisconsin is going to put an
indian guy on her wall you should be a
songwriter
your story wow that's fantastic
what was the name of your boy band forte
there's actually a
the movie based on loosely based on that
story is actually in development
at universal pictures oh sick
yeah are you going to be in it you're
going to start in the movie no i'm
producing it
[Laughter]
me and mark platt and then universal
right now oh wow yeah
yeah uh ricardo how about you um i think
for me
i started out as a musician
at a young age playing instruments
and i don't think songwriting was never
actually a part of the plan for me it
just kind of
how everything ended up happening in my
life i got to know
some great people and some of the best
songwriters in the world
uh max martin and salvan cotesia who's
actually right here
um and for some reason it just came
naturally
in in my career to start
exploring new parts of music that i
haven't done before
or hadn't done before at that point and
it was just um it was so interesting
coming from more of the live aspect or
the the musicianship of it
to be able to craft songs and i was
always so like
when the first i remember first time i
heard that there was like this
secret songwriting team behind
all the big pop songs in the world i was
like oh my god that's like the coolest
thing i've ever heard
it's like really and so i was always
like
and i mean i could never dream
of to one day be a part of that crew
but it i guess once again the universe
you manifest those things
somehow and now i'm in the best
team ever with the best people and i'm
so happy i was
always a band guy and i was in this
hardcore
like hardcore metal band uh
which was kind of almost starting to
take off a little bit
like people were talking about it in a
really like
in a big way sort of and we got some
potentially huge gigs and
like um our our singer
just um he he left to go on another
endeavor and he went
so he left the band and moved north to
stockholm
and then he became the songwriter that's
shellback now that made like uh yeah i
can't stop the feeling moves like jagger
and
stuff like that so then
that was that's that was when i realized
that that's something
that you could actually do um but i
still went on to play in bands for
i mean pretty many years uh
that must have that's 15 years ago at
least and i think i moved up here to
stockholm
five years ago with the intention that
okay i um
like i'm the the band thing is going
like too slow
and i just i want to move like it was
hard to get all the people together and
stuff so i moved and i like started
hammering away then uh
nice uh let's talk about how
the three of you got involved with the
film eurovision song contest
what was it like getting that call had
any of you ever like worked
on songs for eurovision proper how did
you all get involved
executive produced music for the whole
movie so
i got a call from netflix my friend amy
dunning
asking me about your vision she was just
like oh there's this movie and we're
always
for years me and amy have been trying to
find something to do together
and she knew i just started charlie's
angels and i was like
she was like there's this movie i'm
trying to find it's like about
eurovision
will ferrell you know you're around a
lot of swedish people do you know anyone
that would be interested in helping with
this
and i was like i'd do it that sounds fun
sent me the script and she was like you
know
maybe you should try out one song and
meet the director david dobkins and
who i was already a huge fan of um
and i i talked to him i talked to
screenwriter i read the script i loved
the script the first draft that i read
was so funny
and we tried out one song which was
double trouble we wrote one song
and then after that they sort of got the
gig and the way i usually work when i'm
ep
stuff is you know i'm around like these
guys some of the best talent in the
world
so i just sort of gathered the troops
and say like hey
you know they they were working together
them too and and
they said hey there's this thing and
there's these songs that we need and is
anyone interested in helping
and then these guys luckily rose and
when someone asks you if you want to
write a song for will ferrell
potentially
you kind of yeah you say yes
sorry max yeah no no that was the right
answer
it was the right answer yeah
well it's interesting to get the call to
write for will ferrell i imagine is
different from getting the call
to write for any other pop star what did
you find were some of the
like most surprising differences or
challenges
in writing a song for what's basically a
narrative musical versus
kind of a self-contained pop song well
first of all
pharaoh's a lot more sexy yeah no but i
think
i think we went about it the way of i
remember talking to solomon about that
let's write it as
like the characters in the movie are
real um
stars or like pop stars um
and also write the songs just as good
as you would write or any other artist
in the world
yeah make this really like credible and
like
that the song should be able to to be
real songs
basically that's what i'm saying even
though with a funny concept that would
be easy to like oh is it all gonna be
just like like funny things and someone
was like no
let's let's try to write this like as
real songs
real quote-unquote i think you
understand no i think you don't write
down for it
exactly exactly you read the characters
like real art treat them with some
integrity there's a lot in the script so
treat them like
you would if you were in a big artist
session
you brought up the idea of like
heartfeltness and sincerity
there's not a ton of comedy in the song
hussevik
and i'm curious what it was like to find
that balance between kind of comedy and
sincerity
were there earlier versions that had
jokes in it
what was it like finding that balance
looking at it
just coming straight out of outside the
eurovision looking at it
looks pretty like spectacular and
like maybe wacky and
and so we we knew that we had like
comedy and we have
that sort of like context but we we
still wanted to
so so we didn't have to like try hard to
to like make it funny it was rather
yeah finding the balance because it is
like secrets
who's singing the song is going through
a real struggle
and like we wanted that to to really
shine through so
we we tried to get in her head a lot
while writing it
does that involve like speaking with
david about getting into his getting
into her head does it involve
researching like icelandic culture what
did it feel like to get into her head
like that
there's a lot of conversation with david
for sure and and with andrew
um and will actually i mean it was a you
know
mostly david um just yeah
a lot of the answers were in the script
and in the story right guys i think that
her journey of what he was looking for
and and trying to say
to lars is
also something so relatable you know of
absolutely you're in love with someone
who wants the whole world and you just
want them and you go along for the ride
for a minute
you want to say look i don't care about
all this i just want you you're trying
to get approval from everyone
i just want you you know yeah we got a
lot a lot for free so to speak from the
great
script i used astro projection to get in
actually get inside sigrid's head in in
the movie universe
in the future because the film wasn't
made yet but that's one way you talk go
about it
[Laughter]
like max i know you mentioned he'll tell
you got inspiration from his hometown
you know yeah my wife was going through
that
we just moved back to sweden now and and
and not a lot of my friends know but we
were already planning the move around
then
because for very similar reasons we
moved to l.a she's swedish that's why
it's been random we didn't just randomly
live in sweden
but you know she was from sweden and she
moved with me to l.a so i could chase my
dreams
and after it blew up and got in you know
crazy it was just like i don't want any
of this i just want you
and our kids i don't and i want to go
back home i don't want i don't need to
have all this
la hollywood stuff you know and i think
so we're all got to relate to
it in certain ways and i also think that
that was something that a lot of people
that
that watch the movie could relate to
because during that time
they needed to laugh and have a good
time but also like the
the emotional parts of the of that song
is really what solomon just said i think
a lot of people were
you know they realized like the
fundamentals of life is usually
the things that are right in front of
you and the p the people you love
and you know and i think everyone
got to see this like this year it's been
hard for a lot of people
max what about your hometown uh
specifically made it into the song
it was definitely like the the starting
point and everything was definitely
like sigrid's hometown um
and when we were just building the
skeleton of the song we didn't know
exactly which
hometown it was going to be but i like
i was sort of imagining um
her icelandic hometown and
at the same time trying to fetch like
stuff from
my hometown and what i think about going
there so like
again astral projection going there i
started hearing like
seagulls and seeing whales and
water and mountains
nature stuff like that yeah beautiful
and and so my hometown also has like
seagulls
uh that which annoy you
really a lot uh when
like when you're there you you just like
pick the perfect breakfast plate at the
hotel and you go out in the sun you're
gonna
eat it but you just have to get your
coffee and while you're doing that like
the seagulls
like when you get back out they like
they took everything
they mate in the middle of the night
right outside your window
when you try to sleep so like you they
they get underneath your skin but then
also
like when you're traveling around you're
doing all this stuff
like when you get back into town and you
hear
the seagulls it's like the warmest
feeling still like you
you just love coming back to that as
well
i know for a lot of the tracks
there was kind of a mixture of rachel
mcadams and my marianne's vocals
what was that process like kind of
overall during
throughout the entire piece but also
with this song specifically
my marianne is actually a swedish artist
named molly sandeen who who
it was just sort of kismet that she she
you know we wrote this song double
trouble she
was in town and and one of my co-writers
that song was like i was like we need a
girl to sing it before we present it to
david and um he was like oh i have a
friend in town
she can come you know she's a great
singer and turns out she's
molly sanding in sweden is probably one
of the biggest pop stars
and she killed it and when everyone
heard her voice they were like oh my god
she has to sing
all of the songs and weirdly
when we had a day in the studio with
rachel
um who was so so lovely and and and
super shy to sing and and get behind the
booth
and i can understand that you know when
you're hearing molly's vocals
but strangely she had the same like
timber
to her voice as molly so there are
definitely like parts where you could
just sort of blend like in the chorus
and
you know she's always not a singer
singer like molly is but there
there are moments and all the songs that
rachel sings and you i think you hear
or that molly sings and i think you hear
it in the movie when she's when
it's like she's riding my hometown on
the piano
yeah that's all rachel yeah and and you
believe
that that voice sings on stage as well
because it's
weirdly they have the same sort of that
same tone and timber
so it was pretty easy to sort of like
slip her in when you can you know
that's awesome and what was i we talked
about his
objective sexiness what is will ferrell
like
as a vocalist in a studio what did he
bring that surprised you all
he was so nice he was just so nice and
collaborative
you know yeah you know it was it was so
easy
to i mean not that i would think
anything different i guess but he was so
easy to just say
i mean you know if you don't hear diva
will ferrell stories he's
always known to be like um
that would be great for yeah i'd love
that for him though
yeah uh but he was so collaborative it
was very much like me and david
as well like directing him in the booth
you know and like
try this and when we try it like this
and you know
there was a point where we thought we
needed there wasn't enough
iceland a guy's accent and he was such a
trooper and he came in he took as many
takes as possible
he's a perfectionist very collaborative
and like welcome to
like join ideas and ball back and forth
yeah and his wife is swedish i think he
felt home like at the studio because
it's all
all swedes didn't he like rick you say
when he first came
yeah no i was having lunch he came down
and was like like high and swedish
started talking swedish to everyone at
the table and everyone was like freaking
out
it was so funny i was just sitting
having lunch and all of a sudden
will walks in like at our studio here in
l.a and he just
and he stands there and there's that
like moment of like do i say
he was standing behind me yeah know i
didn't see him
i was just saying we were just sitting
having lunch
above my head yeah and then he says he
looks swedish like
how are you guys doing we're all like
i think the weekend was there i think
like other people were there and they
were all excited that will ferrell was
gonna be in
yeah sorry yeah there's something about
movie stars for sure that's it i want to
get a little in the music theory weeds
with y'all
if you'll indulge me um i
love how the chorus is
kind of founded on like a big suspension
resolution that four to the three
i think that's such like a curious thing
to hang a chorus on
i'm curious what is the emotion you
think we get out of that
suspension to resolution were there any
other kind of like
harmonic uh foundations for a chorus you
were noodling on
where did that specific move come from
is that when you feel it here
in your stomach i mean that's what i
feel yeah that's what i
yeah that's that's what i go by i should
write down what you said if somebody
ever asks
for the theoretic part i think i mean i
can only speak for myself i always
try to search for that where where the
melody
like sits in a way over the chords where
you feel uh
we feel something
that part of it like really just hits me
and i'm curious where that came from
i think it just like dropped it just
like
dropped in i think
all those pop writers disappoint people
that know theory i know
yeah for me for me it's about going
i i don't i don't use theory actually at
all while
writing i'm just like listening mainly
i'm listening
like i feel my what i think is my like
best songs so far is
those idea ideas come like when i'm out
walking in the night time or just like a
lot of a lot of
my ideas come they don't come
in the studio in the room like i just
bring music from the studio
and i bring it out and i like i do it
like when
when i get transported when i'm on a bus
or or a train
or just like looking out a window while
traveling and just like thinking about
other stuff then it's just like it just
some a lot of stuff just comes to me and
it feels like
it's so it feels like it's already
written and you have to sing it to
everyone
around you like is this taken no no no
no
or whatever yeah you know what i mean
yeah that's the thing every time you
come up with something you think is
really good
you're paranoid that it's something else
yeah yeah yeah everyone asks everybody
is this something does it sound familiar
does it because you don't you know
learn lines lawsuit got everyone freaked
out
hard precedent to say yeah um were there
any kind of
previous demo versions of this song
that were maybe like very different from
the final product
like sigrid's writing it she was
supposed to like be like with
there was supposed to be another scene
for that then i have a little
cave sounding elvish
sounding version of it that i just found
yesterday when i was oh yeah
material i remember that yeah it was
supposed to be like she's kind of like
humming it
yeah i remember that an astral
projecting herself
to the elf cave i remember that yeah
that's so funny with the
there were so many they were like what
was it how many versions did you count
we have i have i have 60 plus in in one
folder
at least yeah it was a lot of like
because the song was coming together as
they were also figuring out
like what that scene was going to look
like and feel like and
and the story was progressing you know
they
as rachel being rachel being rachel
found the heart of the character and
became the heart of the movie
so then as this song started shaping up
they realized
they earned the emotional moment of the
movie because originally that was going
to be a comedic moment at the end
where they all like beca like broke out
and had an orgasm that was originally
planned
it would hit this note
and then david was like no we gotta we
gotta find her voice a little bit more
like thematically and and
i think as the song developed the film
developed and so there was a lot of
yeah we need drums at the beginning no
wait let's do guitar no wait let's do
just because they were as they were
trying to figure out and while they were
filming
um they were trying different theories
of what that scene would look like what
that shot would look like
they were kind of shaping it shut each
other up yeah they were shaking
each other and then the piano you know
it's so cool i think
that that happened yeah the whole thing
was so collaborative so it really felt
like a part of the
you know it wasn't just like you didn't
feel like you're just writing songs from
the movie you really felt
a part of the story um and how it shaped
which was which was
just an exciting thing i think for all
of us crazy
crazy cool that's cool um
we spoke with david the director
um maybe when it first came out and he
revealed i believe that double trouble
was like this close to going to ariana
grande is that right
no like if the story behind that what
did i get wrong
oh i um no i what i told i had
because the idea was i was gonna have i
think he's just guessing that but that's
not
fact check it yeah no no but i think
he's just guessing because i had that
chorus
in my phone i was thinking of another
artist and i was going to be like
i always record melody's my phone i'm
always like oh okay i'm going gonna go
in with this person of the month or
wherever so i'll just save that and
present this melody to them
in the session and i was saving that for
an artist that was not ariana grande
um but when we needed to find a great
chorus
for the eurovision song i had
just like the melody it wasn't exactly
that it was like around that
and then we shaped it into that um but
yeah it was
was there ever i mean i imagine once you
started writing hussevik you're pretty
locked in
was there ever any thought of like god
this would be a great
pop tune for x artist was there ever
like a
a backup plan for giving it to someone
else not with history because at that
point it was very
it was sort of the last uh like
song and that was the one that was kind
of the hardest to crack but like we
talked about this the story came so much
from the script at that point so we were
ready one of my
very favorite things in oscar ceremony's
past is watching
the nominees for the best original song
perform
and this is going to be a wildly
different ceremony
and i'm curious if y'all have talked or
figured out
is there going to be a performance of
hussevik at the oscars what is that
going to look like
what's the plan there they still haven't
got a solid plan we were just on a call
with them and i think it's a fluid
situation they're still figuring out
i know that they're definitely somehow
there will be music performances as it
looks
right now it's hard to say yeah i just
don't know if they
know when and where you know what i mean
but i think they're all working that out
i mean that's that's not an easy job
those
those i haven't convinced steven
soderbergh yet but
i think like when he sees my performance
into the iphone
he's going to be pretty convinced he is
making my biopic so i should
actually call him and ask him
yeah let's patch him into this call
right here let's get him on the horn i
mean that's another
reason yeah another surreal you know
moment in life
when you're on a zoom and you realize
you're on a zoom with him
and you're like oh wait that's you're
like oh wow that's amazing
cher and jesse collins they're pretty
intense like i mean pretty awesome
legends actually yeah i know
um i've got one last question for you
boys thanks for taking the time
it's a simple question um how jealous
are you
of the song yaya ding-dong
incredibly yeah yeah you can't measure
that
that level of jealousy it's just like
they yeah it's you know in the movie
what like what song
do you have in your head when you go out
in the theater you know
it's a it's in a bar it's they've named
a bar after it so
in husabik in who's the week wow yeah
yeah this movie's had that big of an
impact over there
well whosoever has been campaigning for
us without even we didn't know
about this but they like they they love
it so much the town created a video
like lobbying for it was crazy i mean
not great
it's amazing they've got a yaya
ding-dong bar they put a website they
have like a children's choir singing the
song
i mean it's so heartwarming and you
realize like this means so much to them
and so we kind of all
want to win for hussevik i mean yeah
what a legacy wow
awesome that's the time i have with
y'all thank you so much for chatting
this was such a great conversation
yeah thank you man thank you thank you
yeah take care and
uh break a leg good luck i'm rooting for
you
thank you thank you so much